I'm standing here with a lot you are the
director of the King David Museum is
that right yes the tower of david museum
why don't you show me the different
quarters in the city this is the
Christian quarter Christian quarter over
here this is the Muslim Quarter don't
with a rock beautiful Jewish quarter
must have it you one see because it's
down towards the valley the Armenian
Quarter is right there the Armenians
have a poignant I don't understand why
they get a quarter oh I did have you
hung out in the quarter of your family
gone to the quarter a lot no you guys
don't use it right no you guys are all
hanging out at Zankou chicken a lot of
Christians don't love well especially
Irish Catholics we're loud where you
throw potatoes at each other I promise
you you do not want the Irish Catholics
in here who's gonna be Red Sox sports
bars everywhere no have you been to one
they play that song jump around jump
around over again
[Music]
don't give them a section many ancient
sites here Mount of Olives right Dome of
the rock I love their oh this must be a
very ancient site it says Hyatt Hotel
this must be this is the hotel where
Joseph and Mary couldn't get a room was
completely booked
and they gave it a terrible yelp review
Donald Trump came to Jerusalem yeah and
he was very impressed with Jerusalem he
has a peace plan a way to divide up the
city that he thinks will bring great
peace and harmony here's what he wants
to do right over there that's gonna be a
Trump Hotel that's gonna be a casino
tourists can float around and right here
everybody Muslim Christian Jews will all
live together in one condominium I love
the river and this by the way is real
his face is gonna be projected right
over it's gonna go up in six months and
guess what Mexico is gonna pay for it
markets in the old city they have so
many beautiful things to buy haggling is
a big thing here and I wanted to learn
more about it so this is my Benny Benny
you understand the art of haggling
what's the first thing I need to know
you need to tell them that you saw
exactly the same item in the other shop
less than five you okay so wait
but with that's a lie it's a lie what's
another word in other words the quality
it's not so good it's not so good at
insulting any other tricks yes just to
argue with you argue until you will
break up and you will take down the
price I am interested in buying these
products the Jerusalem had how much is
this honest price $3 $3 that's [ __ ]
three dollars it's way too much so long
yeah and guess what I saw it in another
market for much less weird smell this
market I like I'll buy it at this market
but not for three dollars that's
[ __ ] with you yes my child this is
not the way fifty dollars that's
[ __ ] that's my future $60 for this
guitar still look to the brothers cool
it did
I'll give you 65 70 75 80 85 90 95 how
am i doing
ten dollars how much you want $10 will
give you fight to close no no for this
you're terrible haggling force the most
sacred site in Olive old Jerusalem is
this Alabama Heart of Dixie
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not touching you my hands above you
[Music]
nice so what is your name David David
yeah do you live here yeah this is
beautiful thank you so very nice to meet
you something we could do a coffee let
me talk to your your view if I'm done
shooting maybe later on I can combine
okay tell me about yourself David one
day I have five kids your five kids yeah
19 grandchildren you have 19
grandchildren does your family know that
you meet strangers on the street and buy
your house for coffee do they know about
that
I worry about you I don't want you to do
that like if I could be crazy those are
very hard to come by because nobody
really wants them will you wear this
ever yes
[Applause]
you were the lowest energy human being
very little energy I think your heart
has beat twice you owed this no not
really you know I'm a comedian in
America I try to make people laugh for a
long time and as you can see I'm very
very funny yes you still be my friend
even though you know this is what I do
[Applause]
you